Oo.
Kapag tinitingnan mo ang kakayahan ngayon, sa tingin ko
mahalaga ring itanong:
ano ang road map? Gaano na ba
kahusay ang mga sistemang ito
at gaano pa kakumplikado
ang mga circuit na kaya nating i-execute?
Para doon, nagbuo kami ng napakahalagang metric
na tinatawag na quantum volume.
Minsan mababasa o maririnig mo sa popular na press
ang bilang ng mga qubit, at alam mo,
bilang sukatan ng pag-unlad.
Sasabihin ko sa iyo nang diretso:
ang bilang lamang ng mga qubit sa makina ay hindi isang
magandang sukatan ng pag-unlad.
Ang pag-unlad ay dapat sukatin sa pamamagitan ng
antas ng kumplikasyon ng circuit na kaya mong i-execute.
Ang mga qubit at ang mga makinang ito ay hindi perpekto ngayon —
may mga error na naipapakilala ng coupling ng
sistema sa panlabas na mundo.
Ang pinakamalakas na katangian ng mga qubit na ito —
ang entanglement at ang mga katangiang iyon —
ay siyang nagpapalakas at nagpapahina rin sa kanila
pagdating sa pakikipag-ugnayan
at koneksyon sa labas na mundo.
Kaya kailangan mong bawasan ang error rate
habang pinapataas ang bilang ng qubit —
iyon ang inilalarawan dito.
Kung gusto mong gawin ito nang tama, gusto mong gumalaw sa diagonal.
Ang quantum volume ay isang sukatan na sumasaklaw
sa parehong mga metric na iyon at sa ilang karagdagang mahalagang pagsasaalang-alang.